- [Voiceover] What we
want to do is find the
derivative of this G of X
and at first it can look intimidating.
We have a sine of X here.
We have a cosine of X.
We have this crazy expression here
with a pi over cube root of X
we're squaring the whole thing
and at first it might seem intimidating.
But as we'll see in this video, we can
actually do this with the
tools already in our tool kit.
Using our existing derivative properties
using what we know about the power rule
which tells us the
derivative with respect to X.
Of X to the N
is equal to N
times X to the N minus one,
we've see that multiple times.
We also need to use the fact
that the derivative of cosine of X
is equal to negative the sine of X.
And the other way around
the derivative with respect to X
of sine of X
is equal to positive
cosine of X.
So using just that we can
actually evaluate this.
Or evaluate G prime of X.
So, pause the video and
see if you can do it.
So probably the most
intimidating part of this
because we know the derivative's a sine
of X and cosine of X is
this expression here.
And we can just rewrite this
or simplify it a little
bit so it takes a form
that you might be a little
bit more familiar with.
So, so let me just do this
on the side here.
So, pi
pi over
the cube root of X
squared.
Well that's the same thing.
This is equal to pi squared
over the cube root of X squared.
This is just exponent properties
that we're dealing with.
And so this is the same thing.
We're gonna take X to the one third power
and then raise that to the second power.
So this is equal to pi squared
over.
Let me write it this way,
I'm not gonna skip any steps
because this is a good
review of exponent property.
X to the one third squared.
Which is the same thing as pi squared
over X to the two thirds power.
times X to the negative two thirds power.
So when you write it like this
it starts to get into a formula,
you're like, oh, I can
see how the power rule
could apply there.
So this thing is just pi squared
times X to the negative two thirds power.
So actually let me delete this.
So,
this thing
can be rewritten.
This thing can be rewritten
as pi squared
times X to the negative
to the negative two thirds power.
So now let's take the derivative
of each of these pieces
of this expression.
So, we're gonna take
we want to evaluate what
the G prime of X is.
So G prime of X
is going to be equal to.
You could view it as a
derivative with respect
to X of seven sine of X.
So
we can take do the derivative operator
on both sides here just to make it clear
what we're doing.
So we're gonna apply it there.
We're gonna apply it there.
And we're going to apply it
there.
So this derivative
this is the same thing as
this is going to be seven
times the derivative
of sine of X.
So this is just gonna be seven times
cosine of X.
This one, over here,
this is gonna be three,
or we're subtracting,
so it's gonna be this subtract
this minus.
We can bring the constant out
that we're multiplying the expression by.
And the derivative of cosine of X
so it's minus three times
the derivative of cosine of X
is negative sine of X.
Negative sine of X.
And then finally
here in the yellow we
just apply the power rule.
So, we have the negative two thirds,
actually, let's not forget this minus sign
I'm gonna write it out here.
So you have the negative two thirds.
You multiply the exponent
times the coefficient.
It might look confusing, pi squared,
but that's just a number.
So it's gonna be
negative
and then you have negative two thirds
times pi squared.
Times pi squared.
Times X to the negative two thirds
minus one power.
Negative two thirds
So what is this going to be?
So we get G prime of X
is equal to
seven cosine of X.
And let's see, we have a negative three
times a negative sine of X.
So that's a positive three sine of X.
And then
we have, we're subtracting
but then this is going to be a negative,
so that's going to be a positive.
So we can say
plus two pi squared over three.
Two pi squared over three.
That's that part there.
Times X
to the.
So negative two thirds
minus one,
we could say negative one and two thirds,
or we could say negative
five thirds by power.
Negative five thirds power.
And there you have it.
We were able to tackle this thing that
looked a little bit hairy
but all we had to use was the power rule
and what we knew to be the derivatives
of sine and cosine.